this project is called the caterpillars
Cove study and Child Development Center
I think is a lot of young parents we
become incredibly sensitized to the
quality of design in children's
environments and a lot of the time the
environments that interested them the
most were ones that were a little bit
more abstract a little bit more of an
opening for them to kind of insert
themselves into it and imagine their own
environment it really was the the
concept that stayed with us throughout
the whole design process as designers I
think we bring a different part of our
design baggage and our design philosophy
to different projects so for this one
because it's for kids we wanted to give
them a lot of micro environments within
that space that they could take as just
opening suggestions for how to play one
very important part of this project
which are the little play structures and
what we try to do with those were to
create structures that were suggestive
of things like there was one which they
might think of as a factory or maybe a
dragon so that's where we had this play
space with big sand pits or sculptures
really that they could think of as hills
or islands made out of timber basically
it had the suggestions of a shape but it
wasn't complete for them and was kept
very very abstract for these kids to use
in their imaginative play we feel pretty
strongly that one of the things that's
needed to push the design scene forward
is really to foster the small and medium
size practices the young practices the
presence design award it changes the way
that people think about their
expectations for their own work it's not
just about conventionally beautiful
projects but ones that have design goals
which are not purely aesthetic our
advice to emerging young designers would
be to make sure that when you start your
office that you are ready you're
equipped to take risks take your time
and make sure that you know you're in
the right place to start your own
practice